hello my name is kevin kelly and i'm the
co-chair of the long nile foundation
for 25 years long now has been promoting
long-term thinking
and we asked ourselves who might know
about how to think long-term
and we looked around and realized that
some of the longest lived companies and
other institutions on this planet
may have something to say about thinking
long term
alexander rose the executive director of
the lung now
was employee number one and for 25 years
alexander has been thinking about this
question
recently alexander launched the
organizational
continuity project to investigate this
premise
in a systematic way
even though the project has just
launched and we're just beginning
already the question is
really productive and is prompting
new insights this evening alexander will
report on the genesis
of that project its framework and what
we might expect in the future
i think this is a very exciting work and
at the core of the lung now foundation's
own premise to foster long-term thinking
i look forward to it and i really
welcome alexander
hello i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about a new research project that we've
been working on
called the organizational continuity
project and the goal
is really to start to understand uh some
of the
reasons behind the longest lived
organizations
in terms of how they've lasted why
they've lasted
and if there's any portable lessons that
we might learn as an institution that
ourselves
wants to become a multi-century
multi-millennial
organization the lung now foundation was
started almost 25 years ago
really to be the seed of a very
long-term institution that could survive
alongside some of our more iconic
projects like the 10 000 year clock
that's currently under construction
or our language projects like the
rosetta disc and each of these projects
will have a
hopefully a multi-thousand-year
component and we want an institution
that can both help contextualize that in
civilization as well as maintain it
and really help maintain the information
and knowledge of civilization
as it moves through centuries and
millennia so
in order to create that institution we
realize there really aren't
kind of bodies of knowledge of creating
multi-generational institutions but
there are many of them out in the world
that we can learn from
so this project is hopefully us learning
about how to become one of the longest
term institutions ourselves and what
you're seeing here in this presentation
is the beginning of that research where
we're starting to learn
about some of these oldest organizations
and some of the reasons that they've uh
that they've been able to last
it's an interesting question of why does
organizational continuity matter
the thing that we keep coming to is that
we as society
discover things that are that are really
important information and stories
about how to better survive something
like a natural disaster and i think an
interesting example
in recent times was the earthquake that
started a what's
now considered to be about once in
century event of a major tsunami
there back in 2011 and when those
stories of that tsunami the tragic story
of those tsunamis was going around
this one really caught my eye and it was
a story of these
tablets and markers that were found
throughout japan some as old as 500
years old
or more reading things like high
dwellings are the peace and harmony of
our descendants remember
the calamity of the great tsunamis do
not build homes below this point
and tragically many homes were built
below this point
many homes and property damage and lives
were lost and you know the fukushima
nuclear plant damaged
all of these things because they weren't
listening and didn't have the
organizational continuity
even in a country that is famous for
some of the best organizational
continuity
and maintenance in the world such as
japan and
you know we're now living through one of
the great examples of
um why organizational continuity might
matter it's a you know this global
pandemic
that was a hundred percent predicted and
known event was going to happen we have
within our our own written history many
indications of it we even had
institutions that tried to prepare for
this but actually the governments didn't
listen to those and now we have this
tragic response to
you know an event that really could have
been solved better by having better
organizational continuity so this
this problem is not an esoteric one it
does
it's one that that really has real world
consequences and you know we don't want
to find ourselves
you know just a generation from now or
you know 10 years from now
looking at you know down the barrel of
something like an asteroid impact
again 100 predictable event that we know
is going to cause loss of life
um damage to the to infrastructure um
could cause
a total extinction level event where for
the first time we're a space-faring
species that can both predict these
events and stop them but only if we're
well prepared and we have the
organizational continuity
within our governments our private
institutions
and our science community in order to
solve these types of
large problems so what are some of the
world's oldest institutions
one of the oldest companies that we know
of is a temple construction company
called congo gumi
which was started at the end of the
sixth century at least
and is still operating today now i
believe it's been subsumed by a larger
construction conglomerate but they're
still building temples and still
largely the same kind of operations and
staff one of the oldest hotels in the
world
also in japan the nishiyama onsen
kind of a japanese homestay still in
operation today
one of the oldest restaurants in the
world built in a little after
800 a.d as the stiffskeller saint peter
hotel and restaurant one of the oldest
wineries that we know of in the world
interestingly is the staff elterhof
winery in germany built in 862 as far as
we know
some of the other types of businesses
and operations that we start to see over
a millennia ago
that are still in operation are bars and
pubs
so sean's bar in ireland is said to have
been built in 900
a.d the other thing that we start to see
in the 11th century is the invention and
proliferation of universities
so we have things like the university of
bologna
and uh soon afterwards the university of
oxford and then many of the other
universities in
in the uk and other parts of europe
really start to proliferate
more recently we are are seeing some
more commodity type things
like the poland salt mines in welliska
starting in the 13th century and then
even paper companies like the story and
so
finished paper company in 1288 but
you'll notice that not only are many of
the oldest
organizations in the world in certain
areas like japan and
old world europe but also they tend to
be a ton of breweries
wine makers uh confectionaries in some
cases hotels
organizations that serve basic human
needs one of the other things that you
start to
see when you look at aggregates of
companies that for instance
last for more than 200 years a huge
majority are in japan
so this idea that location matters even
though japan has risen and fallen and
had lost wars
their basic system of government and
culture
has lasted over time and and the other
places like old world europe and germany
and holland and france are some of the
other places that
we see some of the longest-lived
institutions and so the other thing that
you start to see
is that 90 of the companies that are
over 200 years old
also have less than 300 employees
now if you look at more modern companies
like the fortune 500 companies
another very interesting thing starts to
appear
one is that they're kind of financial
service companies there's kind of
universal services that people have
needed over the past few centuries
but if you also look at how long
companies are lasting on the fortune 500
list
it used to be in 1950 that all the
companies on the fortune 500 list
averaged at about 61 years old if you
look at that data now
that's actually less than 18 years that
these companies are surviving
so these are not mega companies they're
not the largest companies
or organizations in the world they're
the ones that
have figured out a niche and a market
size and a size of their company
that can last over centuries at a time
the
thing that comes out of this data if
your only goal is growth especially as a
company
it's very difficult for you to last for
a long time you kind of outgrow
all of your resources and all of your
customers of the thousand companies that
we know of that are over 300 years old
as i mentioned there's a huge section of
this
is in the alcohol industry by a lot
the hotel industry and restaurant and
food food service industry all of which
are kind of in a way kind of the same
market and then as you get down into
this you start to find things like
pharmaceutical companies
financial companies you also find things
like libraries and universities
so i think libraries are very
interesting because they are the place
where
civilization stores its information
to help it understand problems of the
past
solutions for the future and they are
the memory
institution of our cultures and if you
look at some of the oldest libraries in
the world that are no longer in
operation
they're all largely in the middle east
but because of the historical turns of
the world
we lost many of those cities and
libraries and those libraries go back
as far as uh you know almost 4 500 years
in some cases
you look at the libraries that are still
in operation
and that that whole center has moved to
europe and that's because
the organizational continuity within
europe survived a lot of those wars
and so we still have that information
we're able to um
we're able to to access it we tend to
have those languages more than we have
the languages of those ancient libraries
some of the
other oldest institutions that we have
in the world are universities
the oldest of which are at least one of
the oldest is the university at bologna
italy it was started in the 11th century
i think what's interesting about these
is that they have this property of a new
influx of students every single year
and that cycle of students this brings
new energy into the institution
but it also means that that institution
has to make itself relevant
to a different set of people every
single year so the
you know the the universities that have
lasted have done a very good job of this
their commodity is this universal one of
education
but the way that they do it has to be
remarketed to every single year
of student that they have that's helped
them last for a long time but it's also
helped remind the institution why it
matters why it's relevant
what are some of the other ways that
things have lasted for a very long time
one is to
is to have taken a very long time to
have been built
and we've mentioned religion before here
as one of the longest lasting
institutions in the world but one of
their structures that they create
are cathedrals and cathedrals have this
interesting properties that many of them
took
decades if not centuries to to build and
you know one of the oldest ones the
cathedral at cologne
uh germany was started in 1248 took 600
years to build this cathedral
the most dangerous time you find is for
something to last is really just a
generation or two
after it was first built or founded and
that's because
you know it's the institution or the the
cathedral of your
of the last generation and it's no
longer in fashion often people find you
know a different use for that
that property but if you take let's say
600 years to build it by the time you're
done it's already has a different type
of value to civilization
it's a thing that has value for its
antiquity and its cultural
kind of knowledge um and relevance and
you know we see this now with even
modern
cathedrals that aren't even done so the
the sagrada familiar cathedral in
barcelona
um was begun in 1882 we're now almost
140 years into
its construction progress and it's not
done but it's already
a unesco world heritage site and there's
probably few examples of this in the
world
but if it lasts long enough even in its
build process it can become valuable to
to a civilization and that civilization
can then help it last in fact
the tickets that get sold to come into
this thing are really the way that it's
being funded
to get completed in japan we also find
things like the oldest continuously
standing wooden structures
these temples at nara japan were started
in
607 a.d and they have survived all kinds
of
influxes of government and other
societies and even other religions
to this day really because of slow
careful maintenance the roofs were kept
intact
the main timbers are still the main
timbers but they've replaced little bits
and pieces of the outsides
over time and they've allowed them to
last and they in turn
have helped the institution last over
the same kind of time frame
another example only a couple hours away
by train but
a very different strategy are the um the
ise shrines
in japan and these uh date back almost
two millennia ago
and these temples are built in a in an
interesting way that they're not built
at a very long-lasting materials then
they're not necessarily
themselves maintained from year to year
but they're rebuilt
in exact copies of each other in
alternating sites and so you can see
an image of these temples every 20 years
where
the old one is now being deconstructed
and the new one
is being constructed i was lucky enough
to be there about eight years ago
for the rebuilding of the last temple
when the the now princess of japan moves
the
the kind of cultural treasures from one
to the next and so you have the master
builders who are
in their 80s the last cycle of this 20
years ago when they were in their 50s or
60s
they were the mid-level master builders
and then you have people in their 20s
and 30s who are the new builders
all of them learning how to rebuild this
temple and in turn
i think helping that cultural
institution last itself by reminding
that cultural institution of
the reasons it exists and all of the
rights and rituals that go
along with that if we get out of the
institution category and look for some
examples in other areas we start to see
communities of practice for instance
we have evidence of martial arts being
documented back as far as 5000 years
and that these communities of practice
are not necessarily formal organizations
but they do have a storytelling
tradition again from master to
apprentice
that has kept that information around
for a very long period of time
so one of the things that you have to
look at if you're trying to build an
institution
or organization that's going to last for
hundreds or even
thousands of years is really some of the
larger demographic trends i think
often when we look at things like
population growth
which are closely tied in a lot of ways
to how
you know kind of growth economics and
how institutions are judged on growth
is that you know when you look at just
the next 30 or 40 years
you have this you know asymptotic kind
of hockey stick graph
going off into trillions of people which
you know obviously this world isn't
going to support and we're going to have
limiting factors of resources and things
like that that are going to start to
bring population down in fact
when you look at some of the projections
around population they all start coming
down
around the next 50 years and you know in
nature we see this all the time where
you have
a top level predator their population
goes up
as their amount of prey goes up and then
as they eat eat those resources
then the the predator population falls
along with
the prey population and so we're clearly
going to be going through some cycles
like this so
how can we build new institutions and
organizations that are just as good
at living in a world of less people in
markets that are smaller
and really be able to shrink but not
totally die off
and so when you look at these small
hotels or breweries
or even smaller commodity companies the
ones that are going to survive and that
have already survived
survived famines and volcanic eruptions
and huge changes in market and wars and
and
and all of these things they've all
found a way to survive those
and i think one of the things that i
really want to do is start to understand
each of those
so that some of those may be you know
not very portable lessons but i'm hoping
that many of them are portable lessons
that we can look at for creating new
institutions that can last for a very
long time
what's also important is to kind of
understand culture and value systems
we don't want every institution in the
world to last
for a long time there are bad things
that can be perpetuated we've had
you know empires that have been you know
horribly oppressive that have lasted for
a long time
in the last century we had we had hitler
and the nazi reich
who you know hitler literally intended
to set up a thousand-year reich
and i think we're all glad that these
institutions did not last
it's always worth thinking about the
values what institutions should last
some are you know some companies and
institutions
should be fast churn and we should learn
a little bit from them and they should
be replaced by ones that are
that are more important for us um and
it's very important to kind of think
about that
as we're trying to think about how to
build some of the longest lived
institutions
so in nature we have some examples of
ways that that organisms last for
very long periods of time there's clonal
species
such as manzanita bushes or aspen tree
groves these are species where the
individuals themselves die out but their
their dna is replicated through root
structures
of them being continuously reborn and
these can slowly adapt
to things like climate and move up a
hillside or down a hillside to help
its climate so they're not fixed to a
very specific location but have a chance
to kind of move around a little bit
and respond to climate and change and
also if you know an animal or a human
cuts down one of them
they have this chance to live on as at
least their kind of basic
dna programming code and these can last
for
longer than 10 000 years i think they
have some of these that they suspect are
over 40 000
years old and the last example is one of
my favorites it's a single individual
organism that can last for as long as
5000 years
and it's the bristlecone pine and these
trees are found
in some of the highest mountains here in
north america
and what's interesting to me about these
is that they the idea of them was
postulated
before they were discovered so as people
started to core
some of the oldest trees in the world
they found that the ones in the worst
environments
were the longest lived ones and in fact
when they went into the white mountains
and then the snake range
in nevada and california they cored
these trees that are
live well above normal tree line and
found that some of these individuals
last
as long as 5 000 years so by living in
an adverse
environment they have a really kind of
high immune response
to change so one of the things that does
keep coming up in my research
uh is that there seems to be often in
some of these oldest companies and
organizations um
a person who tells the stories and
connects the generation
to generation within companies and
organizations
in some places that's that's highly
cultivated like the temples in japan
but in some places it's very informal
and sometimes it's a you know it's a
parent of a founder
or um even you know in some cases like a
janitor who's
who's been there for decades and tells
the stories of
how certain things survived in the past
and sometimes they're the person that
you know remembers the last plague or
the last
war and can remind current management
uh what what they did during that time
in order to weather it or
if the management is let's say proposing
a new project
this person might remind them oh you
know what we tried that and it really
didn't work and maybe it could work now
with new tools in a new time
but here's why it didn't work then and
so many of these institutions kind of
have this
have this person and um i think one of
the places that i found that it's
interestingly um you know very
formalized is
in some of the cathedrals in europe like
salisbury cathedral which has
been around for over 800 years
and they have a person there whose title
is called the keeper of the fabric which
is kind of my favorite title
for these type of people they have you
know roles of keeping track of the
finances and
basic administrative tasks but they also
have this role of really kind of
bridging generational conversations
and in fact i think what's interesting
about the salisbury cathedral
is that the oldest continuously
operating clock
is the tower clock that's in that
cathedral and that keeper of the fabrics
their
job one of their jobs is to to help make
sure these things are maintained between
some of the wars and difficult financial
times
or technical failures that it has to
recover from
we might imagine how keepers of the
fabric could be cultivated in the
institutions that we have in the world
to help them last these keepers of the
fabric can
in some cases mean the difference
between life and death
an amazing counter example to the very
first one i started this talk with
are the sentinelese tribes of the
andaman islands
in indian ocean and these tribes are
are small a few thousand people but they
have had these kind of keepers of the
fabric to tell
oral traditional stories over as many as
i think
what we now know to be about 60 000
years their island was heavily affected
by the 2004 tsunami
um off the coast of indonesia that wiped
out you know huge chunks of modern
culture and when the anthropologist
arrived at this
largely uh fishing uh kind of sustenance
village
assuming that it was going to be wiped
out in these islands they found them
totally intact
and they asked them you know what how
did you survive this tsunami and they
said
you know this is a tribe that's that's
been on these islands for over 60 000
years an african diaspora tribe for 60
000 years and they have a a
totally oral storytelling tradition
that's helped along by shamans and
chiefs and
and storytellers within their
communities that said when the
when the when the water recedes just
like it does in a normal wave cycle that
it's always going to come back and eat
at least an equal amount
and so when they saw the water receding
during this the beginning
the antecedent to the last tsunami they
ran for the hills
whereas you saw people in modern-day
bangladesh and indonesia
standing on the beach with cell phones
filming the water going out
not thinking that it was going to have
this reciprocal effect so it was this
very old knowledge
these keepers of the fabric that helped
save life
save property save and save culture um
over time and i think the question is
you know who are the keepers of our
fabric
um i think you know private
organizations and religions
interestingly
kind of have these um more than others
um i think you know a lot of our
cultural institutions like libraries
um and museums are kind of hit and miss
on this
um governments generally are pretty bad
at this
but we can imagine that you know we
certainly want government data like
birth and death records
um government data from you know the
world health organization from this
pandemic to the next
we want that information to survive um i
think
the last example i'll give is is of a of
a good
example and the story of kind of a hero
of the keeper of the fabric
who was unappreciated in his time in
another city in japan
and it was a mayor it was a 10-term
mayor
in this city who was dead long before
the last big tsunami
and he actually right he pulled together
government resources and funding
to build this you know actually fairly
ugly massive 51-foot sea wall
pretty high in a city that's pretty far
away from from the ocean much further
away than other ones were
and he was ridiculed and told that you
know that this was a waste of money and
that it didn't look good
and this this sea wall was closed just
in time to save the city
from the last uh from the last tsunami
well as cities all around it who had
only built
you know sea walls that were 30 feet
tall um were wiped out in fact the sea
walls
basically helped keep the water in once
the once the water came over them
and it was because this mayor had a had
cultural memory from tell the stories
that were told to him
by his elders and he kept it relevant he
had enough power within government
and respect um and length in government
to build something that nobody else
would ever have the kind of
cultural power and social power
and economic power to do so we can all
i think take these examples and
try and figure out what institutions we
want to last for a long time
what is the type of information that we
want to last for a long time
and who are we going to have within
these institutions and how are we going
to empower them
to be the keepers of the fabric to make
sure
that we survive the the kind of the
difficulties of the calamities that we
might live through
and more than that really thrive and
have an have a civilization
that can last in the next 10 000 years
hopefully better than we have
in the last 10 000 years so with that
uh thank you so much um again this is
the beginning of research in this area i
hope to come back and
report back especially as i start
talking to many more individuals in
these institutions
about uh what else i'm learning the much
more portable lessons
of these institutions and how they might
help the institutions that are important
to us
going forward so thank you so much for
having me
[Music]
you